it's here ladies and gentlemen the new
series from the minds behind true
detective and the leftovers it promises
to be a mind-bending ride so I hope
you'll join me in discovering the
secrets held within so take your pills
and put your helmets on it's gonna be
one hell of a trip the episode begins
with a crash course in how the universe
came to be billions of years of history
condensed in under a minute but the
voice over here likely read by Justin
throws character who doesn't appear in
this episode pays close attention to one
particular moment how an amoeba mutated
and became the ancestor of everything we
come to know on this planet he explains
that one little event can have an impact
so huge as to change the course of
history what he's preparing us for are
the clinical trials to come imagine if
one drug could solve our sorrows our
deepest insecurities imagine how that
would affect the course of history you
might also notice he uses the word
corollary a few times almost as if what
he's saying to us is from an academic
paper he's writing any Landsberg played
here by Emma Stone wants to buy some
cigarettes but the clerk doesn't accept
add buddy add buddy is an organization
that controls almost every aspect of
advertisement it's as pervasive if not
more than Google or Apple is today we'll
get to know a little bit more about ad
buddy later on the clerk says ad buddy
isn't accepted because the national
database of desires uses it to collect
data and control people a slight jab at
companies like Facebook who've been
known to sell data to say influence
elections
Annie Jimmy's a lock to get some change
when we see the newspaper headline
Blatter Gate Milgram poop bought Empire
in peril this is a nod to Owen Milgram's
family who we'll meet in a bit she
passes men in suits exchanging
briefcases these are men who work for ad
buddy making their money by personally
delivering ads to the consumer in a cafe
any watches a man recollect a story on
how he somehow got to Poland and wasn't
sure how but it probably has something
to do with the pin he wears on his chest
a symbol that shows up in the next scene
the voice-over continues to pontificate
on how we're all connected all souls are
on a quest to connect and without that
connection we feel lost this hints at
what the show is really about playing on
themes of loneliness and man's
purpose in the world a lot of our
characters will find have lost that
connection and thus feel empty searching
for pills to make them feel better we
see an ad for doxed a service that helps
when your online identity is stolen or
revealed to others before it switches to
this one stating everything tastes
better when you're together and look at
that it's the same symbol found on the
cafe guys shirt on the other side of the
post is an ad not all hugs are created
equal by dr. Greta mantel ray she'll
show up again later - Annie passes a pop
bought display in front of Milgram
industries a whole ton of garbage is
trash on the sidewalk like it's out of
business
notice here the book of Don Quixote the
story of a man who loses his sanity and
decides to become a knight a man who
does not see the world for what it is
but what he dreams it to be the
voice-over ends with the man stating his
main goal is to eliminate all
unnecessary and inefficient forms of
human pain something tells me he's
connected to never Dean pharmaceuticals
later on the maniac logo appears on
screen looking eerily similar to that of
IBM's in the 1980s a computer company
large cold and devoid of the emotion and
humanity our voice-over guy claimed
humanity was all about we then meet Owen
Milgram his last name a nod to the
Milgram experiments of the 1960s which
gauged a participants willingness to
obey an authority figure even if it
conflicted with their personal conscious
this usually involved the subject being
told to administer increasing amounts of
electrical shocks to an actor even if it
caused them extreme pain what they found
most of the subjects obeyed the
authority back to Owen he's being tested
for an upcoming trial against his
brother Jed his dad is there helping him
and we learn he's experienced a
psychotic breakdown ten years ago he
recounts his story of how he was
hospitalized while playing with a
Rubik's Cube just like the one found
outside his offices it appears he sees
his brother Jed when he's not really
there he lies when asked if he knows
what's really real stating he's compass
mentis slatton for stable mind not
mentioning his vision of the water
rumbling on his desk the Statue of
Liberty has been replaced with this
statue of extra Liberty a wing at God
threatening holding a lightning bolt and
head whereas the Statue of Liberty was a
beacon alight to welcome immigrants from
around the world the statue of extra
Liberty is a warning stay out or feel
its wrath at or passes with people
wearing what seems like manga hats - the
logo and the tour guide is Russian all
seeming to be a veiled jab at president
Donald Trump and the Russian collusion
scandal notice how their hats are
embroidered with the number 47
suggesting the 47th President of the
United States meaning in this world we
are anywhere from 6 to 14 years in the
future also important to note are their
fishermen wearing logos of companies
almost as if they've leased their bodies
to corporations a juxtaposition between
the supposed freedom of the Statue but
being slaves to corporations the ones
who make the real decisions Owen's
imaginary brother jet arrives who tells
him he's been chosen to save the world
a woman will reach out to him with
further instructions but this is
seemingly all a dream as the popcorn he
was feeding the birds begins to pop Owen
tries to buy a transit pass but is out
of money looks like in the future
technology has really gone downhill
there's an interesting ad to travel to
the moon next to an ad buddies Wanted
sign speaking of ad buddy Owen is
accompanied on his commute home by one
they pass a fun sign of the
repercussions of attacking a poop bot
while on the train he's bombarded with
ads delivered personally by him ad buddy
asked if he's considered doing clinical
trials for a pharmaceutical company
called never Dean while Owen envisions
Annie in an ad for daddy's home a
company that brings single guys in his
voluntary husband's for women who've
lost their spouses in return for
companionship to make matters worse for
Owen he finds out he's on furlough
permanently he throws up in the toilet
where even the paper has ads on it
frustrated he rips off the dispenser to
find the same words his imaginary
brother said to him the pattern is the
pattern Owen listens to a tape in what
seems to be some form of therapist who
knows all about his mental frustrations
how he needs a partner to finish a
mission his brother sent him on well we
see Annie and yet another ad whether
that's actually her or part of his
imagination is yet to be seen at home we
see he's on several medications and has
a self-help book by the same author we
saw Annie pass in the ad the man on the
tape says everything Jed says is a lie
trying to ground Owen
back and reality he flicks his pills and
judging by the amount of them in his
plant hasn't been taking them for some
time he receives a package from never
Dean pharmaceuticals and a call stating
that he qualifies as a hero candidate
notice also the two diametrically
opposed ads in the background one for
toothpaste and the other for Jolly
Ranchers he's a candidate to treat those
suffering from depression and other
popcorn problems is he really hearing
this or is it all in his mind at this
point it should be noted that we can't
take everything from Owens perspective
at face value he's not a reliable
narrator Owen goes to his mom and dad's
for dinner catching the final moments of
his brother's barbershop medley notice
Jed here not imaginary doesn't dawn a
mustache the founding father of the
family has a picture of what looks like
George Washington behind him the first
president and founding father of the
United States
there's a giant painting of the family
and Owens not in it Jed's fiance hasn't
agreed to marry him until Owen is
painted in she's on meds of her own and
Owen talks about going away with her
starting a new life with new identities
as friends were given a bit more info on
Jed apparently Owen was a witness to
whatever scandal he was involved in and
reassures his family that Jed didn't do
it
notice here the rainbow and the painting
one it's very odd and two it fits in in
one of the never Dean's slogans follow
the rainbow
Owen lashes out at his family and his
father walks him to the subway he wants
to help his son buy him a home work for
the company like his brothers but he
doesn't want to
Owen tells him he doesn't have to buy
him off he'll be the good son and live
for Jed apparently Jed is involved in
some scandal involving a woman who his
father says is just trying to take
advantage of the family
Owen lies to his father telling him he's
got a new job and that he'll be away for
a while but he's really off to never
Dean to be a part of the trials we also
get a quick shot of one of the poopbox
in action leaving a blue sanitary liquid
behind again more rainbow symbolism
Aetna Burdine pharmaceuticals he fills
out a form when another patient asked
him what trial he's there for he says
ULP which apparently is the big time
where you'll make a lot of money the
bombs on the forum mean high risk hence
why you get paid a lot he watches as
Annie storms out of the room apparently
pissed off about some
thing before he's called into the
screening room there he's asked to
describe in a word the pictures he sees
pills a hawk and family all things he's
dealt with recently the picture of the
family he associates with suffocation
it's quite obvious what he thinks about
them the screener then says she's going
to ask Owen one final question but she
just stares at him before the green
light turns on and we learn he's been
accepted his defense mechanisms are
fungible meaning interchangeable with
another the screener bow suggesting
there is some sort of Japanese
connection like if you remember the
Japanese businessmen out front perhaps
they are the ones fronting the money for
these trials
Owen confronts Ana asking her if she'd
lost her husband recently or plays golf
at Hilton Head referring to the ads he's
been seeing her in she's called away
when Owens haunted by Jed he says Ana is
her handler and that he needs to make
contact with her by using the code
phrase the pattern is the pattern they
are taken deep into never Dean's lab
where we meet dr. Fujita and Morimoto
the odd numbered patients have arrived
and they must continue without any of
the old problems he's wearing a weird
headphone contraption around his ears
and seems to be sleep-deprived or just
overdosed from the crack he keeps in his
drawer the subjects are escorted to the
pod room where they'll be staying for
the duration of the trial the orderly
goes over the rules no intimacy
cohabitation and any unauthorized
absence for the pod will result in the
termination of the trial
Owen goes to Annie and gives her the
code but she doesn't seem to know what
the hell he's talking about but as he
begins to break down
Annie fearing she might get kicked out
due to his outburst goes along with it
telling him to wait further instructions
so they can save the world together they
are then greeted by dr. Moreau moto and
Fujita who will be supervising them
Fujita takes out a cigarette and Murray
moto tells them not to [ __ ] this up
clearly these two aren't the most
professional what will happen as this
trial begins and where's the
even-numbered test group will Owen
receive further instructions from Annie
and save the world
we'll have to tune in to episode 2 to
find out thanks everyone for watching
this show is really trippy and I think
warranted and explain series so I hope
you'll like to subscribe and follow me
on this journey
stay tuned for episode 2
[Music]